[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will be your driver on this journey
tonight is a very very special edition
of the rhodes 2000
we are hosting our very own championship
night so uh the wonderful mike comer has
organized a tournament that you can join
on chess.com by joining our team and
heading
to a tournament link which i think
ben is going to be able to pull up i did
send it to him
just a few moments ago he's not going to
be able to pull it up
so i am going to be able to pull it up i
am the person
to do it the thing to do is to go
to the tournament of course which is
right here on chess.com but what you
have to do first
is you have to join our team so search
up the st louis chess club
and we do have a team right there
there it is here's our team so this is
what you guys got to join the st
louis chess club and then here is that
tournament right there
and that is going to be starting in 10
short minutes so everyone
in the chat i know we have all gotten to
know each other we've all
gotten to uh improve together these
past well well over a year now but now
is your time to shine
i'm talking to you peter peterson i'm
talking to you pip and chuck
i'm talking to you audi chandra if
you've been following this class a long
time
now is your chance to prove that you
have been paying attention
that you have been learning and by the
way the stakes
have never been higher they've never
been higher
the winner of this road to 2000
championship
is going to get a private lesson with
me what what better reward could there
be i of course
don't normally give private lessons i'm
normally too busy doing all this stuff
for
you know groups of people for the masses
but it's true a private lesson with me
it's a rare occurrence
and it is the prize of this tournament
now this tournament is actually going to
be seven rounds long
and it's gonna be a blitz tournament of
three plus
oh so while we do have some time
to get started here before we get
started i wanted to teach
maybe a little bit of a mini lecture on
blitz games and to do so i want to
highlight
a particular game i had against the
wonderful
jonathan shrantz who many of you may
know
now the purpose of this game is to show
you that
blitz is sort of a funny version of
chess where you can get away
with doing a lot of things wrong and
still win the game so let's take a look
in this game i had white and jonathan
was playing with the black pieces
and we had been playing a long long
match that just wouldn't end
so i decided it was time to have some
fun started off with the move 1
f 3 which is obviously not ideal
and jonathan replied with d5 and so of
course
i follow up with the natural
continuation of
g4 so of course this is
dead lost for white but the point is
when you've been playing blitz for a
while when things are not going
particularly
your way sometimes playing something
completely random and completely awful
is just what you need to you know sort
of get your mojo back
it is a very very valuable thing to get
your opponent into a position
they aren't comfortable with a position
that they don't understand that they
don't know what's going on
because if you can achieve that then you
have sort of leveled
the playing field right if you're
playing a random position
in a three minute game where neither you
nor your opponent know what's going on
you know you're both going to have
pretty good chances even if it is
objectively
bad so i started with f3 g4 jonathan
replies with e5
making a threat by the way don't uh hang
fools mate
so i follow up with bishop to g2 giving
my king the flight square
on f1 knight c6 by jonathan
now d3 and i'm taking over the center of
the board
uh queen back to d8 jonathan
is now potentially showing the downside
to having a really really good position
you start to get a little bit
nervous when you develop the queen out a
little bit early on in a blitz game
perhaps jonathan was looking at some
things like knight f6
when after knight h3 i have actually
in the past won games like this before
when
this queen is getting a little bit stuck
out here on h4
but jonathan was like alright i'm not
having any of this and retreats back to
d8
and then the game continues with d5
takes on e4
and eventually we do develop our pieces
i come out with bishop g5 h6 bishop h4
and then jonathan actually applies with
g5 and
after bishop f2 suddenly my terrible
terrible opening
is not looking so bad and that is often
the case in blitz games
so what's better than playing you know a
terrible opening
and getting a great position i don't
know
that being said there's a lot of game
left to play so let's talk about what
happens because the game
takes a very significant turn in the
next few moves uh jonathan first takes
an f2
i take back and then we get to a strange
looking position
where i don't think jonathan was
comfortable i don't think jonathan knew
what to do here
and that again is the value of playing
something crazy and offbeat
in the game he went with knight to d7
and now i decided to start launching an
attack with knight d5
it's very valuable to be on the
offensive in blitz games
as it can you know once again put your
opponent you know off their rhythm off
their balance
uh jonathan decided to take i take back
and now after knight d4
i take back on d4 develop the bishop out
to e4
then all of a sudden after queen f3 i'm
definitely
looking to play for mate king g7 played
in the game
h4 played by me queen d7
and now we open the h file jonathan goes
after this pawn on g4
but this actually turns out to be a
mistake because after
the move king to g3 black is actually
completely busted here
no way to save this knight so knight e3
played in the game
but this of course loses to check
bishop h7 check rook check and
check mate and that is the story of how
i defeated jonathan schratz with one f3
two g4 so what happened in this game
what can you take away from this
for your upcoming tournament here in the
rhoda 2000 championship
well the point is don't focus too
heavily on
openings don't focus too much on taking
yourself
too seriously it is a blitz game and all
you need to do
is play good tactical chess and that's
enough to win these games
so there are only five minutes remaining
until the start
of the tournament here tonight if you're
just joining once again this is a very
very special edition of the road to 2000
where we are having our road to 2000
championship so uh there's a link in the
chat
please join the st louis chess club team
and then join this tournament the first
place prize gets a one-hour
private lesson with yours truly on the
camera
right now it doesn't happen often but it
could happen
for you so please join in we have just
four minutes until the start of the
event so why don't we take a look
at our competitors here it seems that
there is a clear favorite
in someone named d diaz roane
no clue who this is but they are rated 2
000
and second on the rating list is so much
better than you
who you may recognize uh as a username
from various
other events that is the one the only
michael j
comer uh so are you guys gonna let mike
cummer
win his own tournament absolutely not it
looks like we have orlando a great
scholastic instructor
playing ah and manny there's our first
road to 2000 regular
representing yo those other regulars
peter peterson everybody get in there
play this event
prove that you know this class is worth
something we also
it looks like we have alex who is a
recent uh new employee
we have nick mike who i think i
recognize
from some lectures someone named jai
blexi someone named
yash other people no clue of these at
audi
it's adi i'm sure most regulars
recognize adi from the lectures
he's always here northern fork dwi
the german dwi is here with us
the working and i think that 800 rating
is a little bit misleading dwi has
proven to be
quite the player so keep an eye out on
him
just two minutes left to join everybody
make sure you are
clicking that link in the chat make sure
you are joining this club
we have 14 players in the event so far
that's a good number and we'll see who
comes out on top here we'll see who
comes out on top
i know myself i am looking forward to
this event i always enjoy doing this
kind of commentary
over especially those blitz games keeps
things interesting keeps things fun
uh let me know if this is something that
you guys enjoy and maybe we'll host more
more commentary over these club
tournaments on this
channel definitely not as a replacement
for
you know my normal classes but maybe
something we can do
in addition you know i have a lot of fun
with it and i think you guys might as
well
but that being said two minutes left
join up join
now before it's too late i think you may
be unable to join once the tournament
starts
so minute 40 seconds on the clock get
going
get joining maybe some of you
will find the glory that i found in my
game against jonathan schrantz
ah steve north is in he is northern fork
steve another great regular of the roger
2000 class
all rights counting down the seconds
here
minute 14 minute 13 literally counting
down the seconds
ah he says he's playing two i see you
audi i see you
hassan wants more commentary that's
great that's great
maybe i will be able to provide
[Music]
peter peterson is asking for someone he
can beat but peter peterson
right now the lowest rated player in the
event
definite underdog definite underdog here
with de waring on the new account
uh he's gonna have to face some tough
competition right away
such as steve north in the chat and adi
adi chandra the ringer
keep an eye out for indiana jones 2020
apologies for that username i do think
that movie got delayed
like two full years but indiana jones
2022
i'm looking forward to the new account
when that day does come
thank you everyone who has joined up to
19 players chess playing wolf has joined
chess playing wolf is that the danny
machuca
is that the man in the shadows joining
this event last second i will not be
joining
i am purely here to commentate it
wouldn't make a lot of sense
if i joined my own tournament uh
especially if i didn't win
then i would be embarrassed and we are
underway
the tournament has officially started
let's get going on some games here
uh who do we want to start with i gotta
start with my guy
manny lp looks like we have a petrov
knight e5 and knight c6 okay a little
bit of a strange line here
usually black continues with d6 to kick
the knight away before recapturing on
e4 but instead we have knight c6 and
white is maintaining an extra pawn
but you know black threatens checkmate
we'll see what manny
wants to do against it and i think
definitely
the story of any blitz tournament um
really at any level is the story of the
clocks it's the story of time
management and manny maybe up upon may
have a good position
here but gotta stay level on those
clocks or it's all for naught
we'll see if c myers can put on the
pressure
there okay we get kingside castles by
black
and white now should just develop c3 is
an okay move i might have even preferred
knight c3 bishop e3 bishop e2 anything
to get those pieces in the game
like i said it doesn't have to be about
accuracy
it's all about getting to a position
where you're comfortable and your
opponent's not
and a great way to do that is just to
develop your pieces
uh very very directly but c3
is also a very good move we'll see where
this queen ends up going
if it goes to e5 look out for a d4 push
with the fork
okay instead we see queen d7
which is not my favorite move it sort of
hems in this bishop
uh d4 forces this bishop back i like it
now i think definitely white should play
d3 and castle on the next turn bishop d3
rather and that's what we see
it would be a mistake to play a move
like e5 because it's actually granting
black
some squares that were previously
unavailable
now we see black playing h6 perhaps he
was concerned about
the move bishop to g5 and then we
actually do see the move e5
so uh manny is probably doing this with
the idea of checkmating on the light
squares but i think it was a bit
rushed i definitely would have preferred
to see castles when black would be
suffering with this knight on f6
rather than having it on an active
square okay
queen to uh to e4 is the follow-up
playing for mate
black must play a move like g6 but that
hangs
h6 uh f5 maybe
f5 is the idea for black if f5 and takes
there is
knight takes on f6 look out for a rook
e8 move actually even immediately
wow okay d takes f6 and rook e8 picks up
the queen
caution manny i advise caution this
could go wrong
this could all go very very wrong very
very quickly
this is why white should have castled
just step out of these tactics
before they ever arrive you don't need
to win the game in 12 moves
you just need to win the game all right
manny spots the danger fortunately and
comes back
with queen e2 just keeping that queen
safe
in the meantime let's check up on a
couple other
games going on how is oddie doing
adi up against uh nick
mike here and as i open a second game it
messes up the layout
i'll keep two games open but adi adi is
up
a ton of pawns the underdog in raiding
but you can never count audi out you can
never count adi out of any kind of chess
game
that guy is a fighter that's a free pawn
on d3
audi just keeps collecting rook back to
d2
rook f to d1 this d6 pawn is going to be
falling
looks great for adi chandra all right
back to manny
back to manny just wanted to peek in
just wanted to peek in how's manny doing
manny's setting up some threats now
setting up some threats there's bishop
e6
black is actually now expanding on the
kings side
it's a pretty interesting position here
white of course should
always always always be better with this
astounding
central control and what should also be
better
now that i counted the number of knights
on the board what happened
where did this knight go it was right it
was so pretty on d5
oh no c myers no not
not not knight f4 and yeah with that
you know white should just be winning
this game i believe should just be
winning this game although it is three
plus zero don't
forget three plus zero white may have
more nights
but black has three extra seconds now
zero
extra seconds but they did have more
time briefly
now negative four extra seconds but they
did find a move and as the clocks
dwindled down
it's gonna come down to who is the
speediest between the two players
it's not always about how good you are
sometimes about how fast you are
okay bishop takes e6 maybe manny just
can't get bogged down trying to
calculate moves like 98
it's much more important just to keep
the keep the moves coming
keep the flow going if you start pausing
and thinking
trying to win more material that is when
things are going to get out of hand and
you'll find you'll
you'll find yourself with no time adi
chandra has somehow drawn
by stalemate adi no not
stalemate oh you hate to see that you
hate to see that but okay the action
continues here
manny with a great position but the
clocks are falling
manny now with less time even that
should never happen
not when you have the better position
who cares about your center
just play chess moves just take it just
move get the rook in
just keep it coming keep it coming keep
it coming quickly
okay rook c6 bishop h6 that's the winner
that's a winner right there the queen
will die
or maybe the queen won't king h2
pre-move okay
ah and manny's queen falls but manny
understands
the name of the game here the name of
the game is blitz chess
as in fast not slow and
despite the material deficit manny
is converting with what i would say is
arguably perfect technique
tough to argue with the move rook to d6
being imperfect technique great stuff by
manny that's how you win a blitz game
that's how you win a blitz game doesn't
have to be pretty just has to win
all right who else won their first round
we have our number one seed
d diaz winning his first round uh danny
also wins in their first round uh with
one point
uh we have magic m1 uh who i did not see
joining the tournament but they have a
point as well
dwi with their first win of all time on
chess.com
has a point uh ruben dario medina diaz
has a point as well j blexi g
naren and then we have our two players
nick
mike and adi uh both on a half point
everybody else off to a rough start mike
cummer off to a rough
start how did that happen mike how did
that happen we may never know because
the next game is underway
this is going to be the game we follow
here
we have dwi who is massively underrated
against the number one seed
diaz and we have a c3 sicilian
all right let's see what we're working
with here and a quick
bishop takes c3 white now has the bishop
pair
uh but black has a good light squared
setup uh that is what you really aim for
against these pawns
white is going to look to achieve the
move c4 without making too many
weaknesses and
d diaz does achieve it and now black
is going to look to pressure these pawns
from the front here
with the pawns on d4 and c4 i don't
think white should be any worse
but black is definitely still in the
game and it's very very easy to let one
of these
one of these pawns slip if you are not
very careful with the white pieces so
yeah rook c8
and rook d8 as expected black now
pressures these pawns down these files
you can expect white to bring this rick
to c1 as well
and then it becomes a question of can
white
do anything with the extra space and
after this move bishop g5
it's looking like maybe they can
although
questions are being asked of the d4 pawn
as well
complicated position i like this move
bishop g5
by white it puts on the pressure on this
knight
and yeah i don't think this pawn is ever
going to actually be capturable
so what is the character of this
position white has
extra space with these two pawns
compared to these two pawns however
these two pawns are a lot weaker than
these two pawns so
black aims to pressure these pawns white
aims to use that extra space
in order to launch some kind of attack
on the king in most cases
so look for moves like 95 to be coming
in the meantime black went for a very
strange h6 g5 push in order to break
this
pin and maybe this was a good idea in
this case that pin was very very
annoying
and now look out for knight e4 94 even
immediately i think was quite strong
aiming to take this bishop and fracture
the pawns on the king's side
also hitting this rook on d2 still
knight e4
yeah and there it go there it comes
dwi does take on g3 immediately even the
move f5 there
looked quite tempting just cementing
this knight on the e4 square could have
been powerful
now how to continue knight a5 by dwi
aiming to activate this bishop as well
and what's this what's this the tr the
future has been foretold
once again white got a little bit
careless with rook d3
and now the c pawn suffers the
consequences that's the danger of these
positions
you get this extra space but those pawns
they do
sometimes just drop off the board and
that's what we see here
what should white have done instead i
don't think white's plan of
doubling on the d file really made any
sense
your goal is oftentimes not to really
push d5 in these structures
it's to go after the king you have to
launch some kind of attack
knight e5 had to be played a little bit
earlier on and then i think white would
have maintained some advantage
instead though dwi with a pawn to
the good here we see rook c2 black is
aiming now to invade on the second rank
also knight c4 threats and this queen is
looking very
short on squares f2 the only square
available
okay rook d2
maybe queen b4 now activate this queen a
little bit
this is the part of the game where black
needs to pick up the pace
as in the previous game with manny these
two players are a little bit
higher rated but that doesn't mean that
same idea
uh doesn't apply here when the clocks
get get below a minute
the position matters less and less
what's important is
who can make normal comfortable moves
the fastest
and right now that appears to be diaz
okay knight c4 is not a bad idea by
black even if
it is a bit risky and i think this was
missed i thought
bishop takes c4 was black's idea but
instead rook takes c4 is sacrificing the
exchange and now
d5 is making some awkward threats
awkward threats for for black to deal
with here okay we see e5
but this cannot be correct now white
will have a past pawn
and black is going to struggle in this
endgame to keep things together
queen d7 bishop e6 is a blockade
but i'm not sure it's going to hold and
most importantly
diaz has been able to keep the pressure
on
the clock and that is what's going to
make the difference
in this game queen f6 white can aim
for some checkmating ideas now although
it is difficult for this rook to get to
the eighth rank
uh just queen e7 was the point wow
yeah black should avoid this trade but
now yeah
d7 uh one last trick
but it's not meant to be dwi it goes
down and the number one seed
maintains the leader's spot
any other game still in progress let us
find
out here manny's game is still going but
let's check in on
g naren against magic m1
and it's a time scramble go make a move
everybody just pre-move gene aaron was
down on the clock
made a couple fast moves but magic m
comes in with the clutch
check at the very end to seize victory
all right where do we stand
after two rounds we still have three
players
on a perfect uh score d diaz who we
followed
we have danny the chess playing wolf
with the perfect score
and magic m1 with that dirty flag
is also catapulting himself into the
leader's
position only three players with the
perfect score
by the way our two players that drew in
round one
nick mike and adi both winning their
second game
moving up to one and a half tied for
fourth place
and then i'm sure we have a myriad of
people on
one out of two ah and what's this jai
blexi
defeats manny to jump to two out of two
as well uh incredible stuff so far these
are exciting exciting games
ah and steve north has won by forfeit
unfortunate uh manny
blaming the internet of course as always
uh when in doubt it is the internet's
fault okay these look like some pretty
big mismatches
so i'm not going to follow the top
boards in this case why
don't we follow who should we follow who
should we follow maybe we should follow
uh adi let's follow audi's game here
against alex alex the front desk
employee
versus adi the long time stream watcher
and i believe photo editor for the st
louis chess club uh and what do we have
here adi is
adopting a more systematic approach
going for
e4d3 looking to fianchetto this bishop
in the meantime alex going for rapid
play on the queen side
yeah knight a4 is always a little bit
uncomfortable when it can be met
by queen before check but yeah adi
navigating the difficulties
finding c3 to defend this knight and
it's alex who's on the back foot here
it is definitely alex on the back foot
but how to continue for adi now
unfortunately
things are still awkward with this
knight this knight cannot retreat it
cannot come to c5 it cannot come to b6
and what does that mean that means b5 is
a threat
audi pulls out the move d4 to try to
solve this issue now b5 would be met by
a knight takes c5 but i'm curious
what is the response to pawn takes on
d4 simply knight takes d4 and if b5 now
are we going to see
b4 in response this is
exciting chess by uh by audi here up
against
alex okay we have a trade on
c6 and e5 by
audi so audi foregoing early development
i would have liked to see bishop g2 in
kingside castles a little bit earlier on
but it's all you know for the sake of
making early threats we finally do see
b5 i think b4
is the only move for white but i do
think it's good enough if you try
bishop b4 then cb4 and bishop d2 gives
me time to save my peace
instead we see knight to c5
and what's this a fork of the king and
the rook not bishop takes c5
is what i expected with b4 to follow adi
doesn't even take any of it
he just leaves the rook hanging says i
have a fork whenever i want it
but i have my doubts about this
particular variation uh
too crazy for me too crazy for me it
looks like black should be keeping the
peace at the end of the day here thanks
to queen
b6 attacking this bishop now black
should have time to save this knight
and the play will continue
uh looks good for alex i think
you know while the complications could
have gone either way in that
particular opening i think they have
broken here for alex
adi put up a valiant effort and will
continue to fight but this one
looking good for alex and that is a
queen you hate to see it
for adi all right let's check in on the
leaders now let's see
how magic m is doing against d diaz
looks like magic m has a perfectly
reasonable position a little bit of
extra space
um even material and uh perhaps an
attack against this king
all right how is danny the chess playing
wolf doing
danny is doing uh pretty well it looks
like doing pretty well
this um i don't know how we got here
with no king side pawns for white but
danny seems to be out for blood
which i thought was more of a vampire
thing to do
but turns out chess playing wolves
they're out for blood as well uh tough
yeah knight to g4 so what is the threat
the threat i think is knight h6
queen g6 when checkmate is coming no
danny just takes on f6
but i don't know if i necessarily like
this decision
by danny trading off okay take back on
e5 now we'll remove this knight
and i think again queen g6 is going to
be the winning idea here uh danny just
needs to
to play it i don't know why he's not
okay we do see queen to g6
knight f4 check is i think the only
reasonable try
bishop takes rook takes queen check king
f8
is on the run but what's going on here
actually
what's going on is black getting away
with it this time there's sort of
counter checkmating ideas i think this
one should break in white's favor
queen h7 check king f8 perhaps the
surprising move
king h3 is playable
if rook ah maybe the simplest is rook a
to f1 you neutralize this rook by
pinning it to the king
and if that rook cannot move then uh
white is never going to get checkmated
right
uh instead we see queen hha check and
now rook 8 f1 does come
and i do like this decision by danny now
king h1
is safe as can be
safe as can be no checks available queen
h4 is met by queen takes h4 when that
rook remains pinned
and that will be the match uh alex by
the way does end up defeating adi
uh in their game and here jay blexi is
just accepting defeat with the clock
running low
and that's a third win in a row for
danny by the way
magic m who is this person ah another
new account with a misleading
rating perhaps our number one seed dds
has fallen
to magic m we liked magic m's position
but how did it happen we have uh
f4 here takes takes queen eight we saw
it here now
c5 is the interesting idea potentially
hanging an e pawn
uh black captures but now bishop d3
check
king here and rook f7
and was it a blunder or a sacrifice the
open
b1 to h7 diagonal now is where white's
going to aim
to attack we have bishop c3 and then wow
the
the very bold queen c5 just placing the
queen opposite the rook
and eventually we see the bishop age
seven sacrifice
and wow what a beautiful game check and
mate magic m taking the lead uh i look
forward to this matchup between
danny and magic m for the sole
first place lead the only two players
left with a perfect score
in the meantime we have alex moving to
two out of three manning to moving
moving to two out of three we have d
diaz falling to two out of three
dwi is up with two points steve north
has two points as well
uh ruben dario medina diaz also has two
points
as does keshev garg and yeah
two players on 50 still all right fun
stuff
let's check out this leadership match up
here ah and we have
danny starting with the brave f6 king f7
perhaps he saw
the pre-tournament lecture here on what
to do in your blitz games we'll see how
this one works for him though e6 and
knight c3
i will say danny has already made a
fatal mistake in spending 20 full
seconds to play these moves
if you're gonna play bad moves you might
as well play them quickly
no reason to take your time arguing the
benefits of f6 king f7 or e6 king e7
you know do i play e6 afterwards no
reason think about it just play moves
and now we do see danny taking an edge
on the clock
we do see that edge on the clock here
okay
b6 by danny he's finding some way to
develop these pieces
kingside castles is normal enough
normal enough okay bishop b7
and the problem here for black is that
his position is
bad why is the position bad well f6
and king f7 are not the most useful
moves in the world and in fact in this
case they are
somewhat harmful actively to the
position we'd much rather have a knight
on f6 allowing us to control e4
but now that's simply unplayable thanks
to this pawn
being in the way and we do see e4 now
by white now if you recall we had a
similar position between d diaz and dwi
in a sense that you know one side had
two
further advanced pawns granting them a
spatial advantage
but the other side is going to look to
pressure these pawns in order to find
some counter play in this case of course
it should be a very
very good version for white here
with this king stuck on a weak square
and these light squared weaknesses
ready made for an attack in the meantime
though look for danny to put some
pressure on these pawns if one of these
pawns falls and then i do think danny
is surprisingly going to have the edge
after the slightly suspect opening oh
an e5 is a nasty move to see white is
now looking
to open up this e file and go directly
after e6
bishop b5 though this is a little bit of
a misstep now is not the time to be
making
one move threats you need to advance
your light square
play c6 comes with tempo for danny this
bishop retreats i expect to see b5
forcing this bishop even further back
and was that a pre move by dany danny
anticipating
the e takes f6 capture in premoving his
response
danny now up 40 seconds and if that's
not an advantage i don't know what is
knight d5 coming now and even the board
position is no longer looking so bad for
black
yeah and this is exactly what you should
do right just pay attention to my
lectures
and then use what you learn and you will
win the game
alright we have h4 by white
and yeah white definitely should not
give up the attack on the king here
that is sort of the major problem with
black's position
uh also by the way is a pawn hanging
perhaps
there is a takes takes in queen takes
problem
that both players are ignoring for the
moment okay now this knight has to leave
h7 is hanging but there's rook h8 to
follow
very unclear what's going on what is
very clear is that dany
is building this time edge and i
would be very surprised if this game
didn't make it to a time scramble ooh
queen d3 though some accurate moves here
by magic m is going to keep the pressure
on bishop g6 check might be playable
okay queen here and is f5 a problem
i think it is f5 is missed though f5
interfering the connection between these
two pieces would have been
winning a piece g4 is an attempt to stop
it but
perhaps f5 anyways you know danny just
plays king eight
and i like this from danny because
whatever he does he does quickly and
that's all that matters here
yeah sacrifice a rook doesn't matter
just get the king
out of harm's way and your opponent will
lose on time
95 that's a free knight i'm taking that
piece
i'm taking that piece bishop takes is
the idea maybe queen b4
queen takes e6 as a threat though queen
takes e6 as a threat
okay it's it's coming on the board now
king d8 though
or king c7
and six seconds is just quite simply not
enough
time danny will be able to win this one
just removes the final attacker and
now knight d6 is even preserving an
extra piece
okay king d7 losing losing the rook
actually i did not even notice this
but four seconds is going to be tough
okay now 3.9 seconds king d6
check that was not made in one the
knight covered
the knight did cover perhaps king d797
should be played king c7 instead
and yeah danny is perhaps slowing down
a little bit too much okay now knight h4
picks up the queen
now knight f4 picks up the queen both
knight checks would have picked up the
queen and we see
danny getting the win taking those life
lessons
from the mini pre-lecture with f6 and
king f7
alright who else who else is still
playing here danny our only player with
a perfect score
uh we have dylan
l0215 who was losing on time
to bogo taco bocco taco now that's a
good name
does bogo taco play the bogo bogo taco
does not play the bogo i'm very
disappointed mr bogotako
very disappointed but congratulations on
the win
i believe that concludes the round danny
now the only player with a perfect score
we'll see if he redeems that that free
lesson with me dwi
also claiming his way back up with three
out of four
manny with three out of four diaz with
three out of four alex
and magic m1 all on three points who
should we follow today
right now who are we following in round
five
we are entering the latter half of this
tournament actually we already did enter
the latter half of this tournament
why don't we check out northern fork i
want to see
steve north in action here i'm going to
flip the board because steve
is definitely a regular at the roger
2000 show okay we have bishop c4
and d6 by black so i know
many people are beginners here and this
is unfortunately how a lot of beginner
games
go they sort of know that they're
supposed to do something like e4
e5 and then they sort of slowly just
develop their pieces
and oftentimes they run into traps like
the fried liver
which is exactly what's going on here
now normally
the fried liver comes about in
this particular move order bishop c4
knight c6
knight g5 d5 over here we first saw a
four knights
and then black unfortunately had to lose
a tempo here so this should just be a
very good version
for white so
what's my advice to you beginners who
are running into these traps
so early on well my advice to you is
it's never
too early to start thinking about your
chess moves okay just because you're in
an opening doesn't mean you get a free
pass to not
think until you're in the middle game
the opening is
still chess and as such you still have
to be thinking about threats
responding to threats and worrying you
know concerning yourself with making
threats as
well just because it's the opening
doesn't mean you don't have to think
okay steve though is surviving for the
moment
white is pinning the c pawn to avoid the
threat of c
takes b5 and i like what steve is doing
here just getting developed
steve's going to castle and develop the
light squared bishop
and then we will we will have a chess
game on our hands okay bishop b7
a3 is a very strange move
bishop g4 now comes with tempo and this
is a counter
this is a counter punch by steve once
again never too early to start thinking
about these things
bishop g4 is gonna remove the queen from
this diagonal
and then this bishop on b5 is simply
hanging
that's a free piece for steve excellent
recovery
from the slightly tricky opening and not
only is steve recovering on the board
he's recovering on the clock as well
jay blexi is going to have to uh to pick
up the pace here
you know it's sometimes very very
difficult to sort of switch gears like
this at a moment's notice
right one second you're on top of the
world you're winning out of the opening
and then the next your opponent is
picking up a piece but that doesn't mean
you should slow down you got to keep the
flow going keep the pace going
okay queen e3 in queen takes e5 i like
these moves
by j blexi here and
honestly black may still be in for a
little bit of trouble here steve just
castles and says take my bishop
on e7 i think a better try was first
knight c6 attacking the queen and
defending the bishop and following that
up
with castle's king's side steve though
is going to get a few
extra free you know tempo moves against
this queen in exchange for this bishop
queen b4 is now forced knight c6 can be
played
but maybe this pawn on b5 is an issue
uh simply h6 and this knight is almost
trapped wow
wow crazy stuff going on in this game so
far i do think knight e4 is playable
uh knight h3 or f3 is really gonna be
asking
for some trouble uh bishop would the
bishop would capture
in that case and rip open the king's
side we do see knight e4 though
okay we see takes once and now maybe
knight c6 no f5
i think knight c6 might have been
winning a piece i thought this was
steve's idea
the exact same tactic as bishop g4
looking
to remove the queen from the defense of
the knight
but ah perhaps steve's smarter than i
knight c6
would have been met with knight f6 check
picking up this bishop which is why we
probably saw
f5 and now this knight's getting kicked
around the board and we'll see if steve
manages to uh to corrally here
knight takes b5 by the way maybe bishop
e2 is a double attack
this game's just all tactics but the
thing to notice here
j blexi 30 seconds on the clock not
enough time
northern fork steve north with a full
minute
is definitely in a commanding position
on the clock
what on god's green earth is rook d for
steve what are you doing
rook d4 was not it bishop e2
and i suppose this is the counter
argument to most people
who you know don't agree with me
on the clock being so important it's
that well sure
i can play moves quickly and all but
then you're gonna get moves like rook
rook d4 and my opponent's gonna take my
pieces for free and i'm gonna lose on
the board
and that will happen sometimes that will
happen sometimes i tend to agree
but that being said by uh getting so far
ahead on the clock steve
has successfully put himself in a spot
where he's not even out of this game yet
i can definitely see
at this level uh even at higher levels
this game going either way depending on
who's the faster player but steve you
got to play a move here
got to play rookie 8 or something rick
c8 blunders97 but you got to do
something
you can't just let the clock run out
steve your time advantage where did it
go
ah and he just resigns too much respect
too much respect i would have played on
i would have played on in the meantime
though what games are left
dwi against magic m1 let's check it out
here
dwight down a queen but he knows what
blitz is all about he's gonna play on
try to play for that flag uh but it's
looking like he's a bit too slow here
magic m seems to have the clock lead
okay some pre moves now will we see a
repetition perhaps
ah queen takes c1 and that does the
trick for magic m
well done finding the check there to
take the win away from dwi
and where does this leave us this leaves
us with no games remaining
danny machuca still with a perfect score
five out of five
magic m and alex wow two of the three
top five are employees that's just
unacceptable we gotta get
some of these regulars to do a bit
better i'm looking at you dwi i need you
to pull this one out in the last two
rounds
looking at you manny with two wins uh
away from the lead
ah and by the way adi and gene erin
both on a level score still bogo do it
still up there
northern fork still up there and wow
we're up to uh
25 players in the tournament thank you
guys so much for uh for joining
thank you all right let's take a look we
have
the showdown of the employees here with
alex the danny we'll see if
danny who is a st louis chess club
almost
oh gee how he will do against the new
the new recruit uh alex with the white
pieces here
and danny once again is
is quite seriously paying attention to
that opening lecture that i taught
coming out with b6 bishop b7 and a5 a4
just taking some queen side space uh is
danny
and as his reward he's snapping off this
bishop on d3 this is a useful bishop
for white it may look a little bit
stunted behind these pawns but later on
white is looking to push e5
open up this bishop and deliver
checkmates so
getting rid of that light squared bishop
is in fact an accomplishment
for black here especially with less
space okay bishop g5 black goes h6
and we'll see danny expanding now with
g5
i expect knight f6 to come uh no
h5 danny's trying to trap this bishop
and i'm loving the way danny
is playing this tournament uh fun stuff
fun stuff
okay f4 by alex h4 bishop f2
and alex's is sort of doing the right
thing here
with the move f4 when your opponent
leaves the king in the center you should
strive to open files open things up and
then
that's when your extra pieces are going
to be useful
and danny also does the right thing to
play g4 and not allow the opening of any
files
but now alex is going to be able to
start taking over in the middle of the
board with moves like d5
moves like e5 and i'm not so sure where
this knight's actually headed
okay h3 g3 is now forcing some light
squared weaknesses taking advantage of
the fact that white is missing the light
squared bishop
bishop d4 i think is actually going to
be the wrong idea here by alex when you
have so much extra space
you want to shove it in your opponent's
face and make their pieces suffer
when you allow trades that is when
uh the lack of space becomes a little
bit less relevant if
you know you have no pieces to use with
all your extra space
then it doesn't really matter a great
deal
similarly if your extra space isn't
really stunting any of your opponent's
pieces
then it is not going to be important
danny once again trying to lock things
down with f5 and once again
that is the thing to do when your
opponent is
better prepared to handle the opening of
the position with the safer king
and alex lets it happen i would have
been tempted to try something like e
takes f6
but we see just maintaining the center
here
and wow bishop a6 the surprise move out
of nowhere
is pressuring now along this diagonal
and danny's position is is probably
significantly worse
but you know i'm starting to see the
light of day the light at the end of the
tunnel
is is coming through he's got he's the
first
to arrive on the c file uh if he can
just
force one last closing of the position
some d6 e6 some e6 d6
then maybe he's going to survive this
one queen d3 by alex and now queen c7 if
rook c1
i think the simple queen takes c1 is on
danny's mind
okay yeah and danny gets the trade of
the queens now and with the trade of the
queens
i'm officially calling it black is
better blank is better here okay
after this move maybe not danny should
have just kept the c file if he keeps
the c file
black is better you know it's the only
open file on the board
the weakness of black's king doesn't
really matter and black is is going to
be the first to invade
instead though you know this is still
going to be a game
after the move c5 white now has some
targets to aim for
on f5 on a4 on c5
and meanwhile black is still on the back
foot
probably rook f to be 8 now if i had to
guess
okay king f7 but now we can take
rookie six is the idea maybe rook e8
is on danny's mind no just knight g8 but
now rookie six
makes a threat connect back to e3 alex
just keeping it calm
and alex uh once again has done a great
job
of staying ahead on the clock we'll see
if danny is
actually going to be able to make up
this time deficit
and now is that a free pawn on d5 is
that a free pawn on d5
maybe maybe not rook d one rook takes d6
was the idea
okay rook f to be eight does come now
and this b2 pawn is weak
and alex is going to be losing this pawn
but
you know once again and that's the
danger of playing quickly and i think
it's a danger alex was
you know happy to take on here alex
willing to sacrifice some of his
positional gains
in order to stay ahead on that clock now
rook takes d6
and danny just does not have time to
figure this figure this position out
king f7 and alex has more than double
his opponent's time
94 the king will move but what danny
but what's okay this move is almost
checkmate but it's not quite oh rook c3
that's a bit unnecessary bit unnecessary
but alex it's a race to checkmate
will danny make it will he find the mate
rook d2 rook d2 rook c1 was mate and we
have a draw by repetition
we have a draw by repetition oh my
goodness rook d
chew check king e1 rook c1 shaq is
mates but instead danny maintains his
narrow narrow lead
by drawing with alex there what an
exciting game
my goodness and this is the final round
this is the final round now the only
person who can catch
danny is now alex mullering
the new recruit so one of these two is
gonna be your champion
one of these two will be your champion
and who else
to take down danny then mike
cummer in the final round it's a matchup
you couldn't
make you you couldn't you know you
couldn't script this
okay you couldn't script this mike has
to take out danny in the final round
meanwhile alex has to take down the
number one seed to catch him
for that first place spot and maybe if
they tight we can orchestrate some kind
of play off i think
that is definitely the the only fair
result here
but for now let's keep an eye on danny
the mic let's see what we can do
at first glance it's looking good for
danny he seems to have just captured a
pawn on g5
and despite having this king on f2
maybe things are are not so bad okay
rook g3
makes a threat but queen h4
it's going to be very very difficult to
save this rook
in fact i think it's going to be
impossible to save this rook
e4 is the correct idea now if f4
knight h6 knight f5 is difficult to stop
uh okay what is this what is this
what is this everybody everybody missed
this
danny's getting obliterated danny is
just getting demolished by
mike what is going on
what is happening as mike would say okay
bishop e5
now f4 but what if knight h6
queen takes e4 wow this is too much
this is just too much bishop takes f4
what is mike doing
oh my god and then e takes f4 obviously
queen takes e4 with check had to be
played but now
now mike's tactic works he takes on g3
all of white's rooks are gone they both
died
devastating okay danny getting destroyed
that means it's all down to alex
can alex do something against dds if
alex wins this game he puts himself
in a tie for first place okay knight f6
is a threat is knight f6 a threat
they seem to think knight of six is
there maybe you have to include this
okay rook c1 defends the bishop
knight d6 is coming this is a great
position for alex except for the fact
that alex just blundered his bishop for
free
okay with the bishop off the board i
am less than enthused about um about the
position
you know i thought we were gonna see the
miracle finish
where alex takes down the number one
seed and uh
and mike cummer plays spoiler as mike
does love to do but uh but no
alex is in a tough way here
and the night falls as well ah alex had
been playing so
so well this whole event all right let's
jump back to
danny then see if he can somehow stage a
comeback here
in order to uh win with uh
without a doubt right you know he would
win with a loss here most likely
but that's not the way danny wants to do
it knight c4 now
and uh oh look out mike look out
danger is knocking at your front door
and bishop e5
will pin this queen to the king what a
game
what a game what a road to 2000
these players are on uh yeah the queen
is falling
then doesn't even have to take right
away it could improve the bishops first
he does capture though fair enough a
free queen is free
okay we see night out to a5
and the game's not over believe it or
not white has a queen and a bishop
for two rooks and a pawn that's almost
even material
not quite but almost
danny though is a little bit behind on
the clock again
we'll see what it can do here g3 is not
the move
h2 now knight f5 knight g3
mike cummer might be winning again mike
cummer might be winning
in fact how do you stop how do you stop
queens
how do you stop white black from making
a queen you don't stop it this is
nothing
white takes here okay now now rook b6
yeah okay there's a check danny's
finding the way he's finding
finding the way now there's queen to uh
to e5
to save the g3 pawn that was
playing with fire if i had ever seen it
that was definitely
close to a knight takes g3 h1 queen
disaster for dany that being said 13
seconds left
13 seconds can danny do it mike still
has threats
okay mike has fewer threats now but it
has more time
okay danny has to move uh he's just too
slow
a6 it's just too slow it's too slow
danny he's not gonna make it
he's just not gonna make it 2.1 he found
the pre-move
okay he's pre-moving now he's gonna take
are we gonna see a draw okay mike saves
his final pawn
saves his final pawn oh and danny had
the right pre-move
that's a draw danny finishing strong
with two absolutely wild draws losing on
the clock but finding some way to
level the playing field on the
chessboard our final game
still in progress here is c myers
against variation sorry
and it looks good for vary but
once again we see the clocks running low
uh yeah black though is able to just
make a queen here
and this will uh will spell doom
for white although the rook has fallen
now okay the pawn pushes
and then what then check over over
over that's the game and with that
the tournament has concluded the
tournament has concluded
your road to 2000 champion is officially
the one the only danny machuca
the chess playing wolf and in joint
second place uh or apparently second and
third on tie breaks
is magic m1 who put up a very strong
showing
and d diaz the pre-tournament favorite
alex
had a chance had a chance in those last
two rounds to win it all
but ends on four and a half out of seven
with that draw against
danny mike also ending on four and a
half out of seven
with another crazy draw against danny as
well
and then the road to 2000 regulars dwi
and i manny both on four out of seven
very respectable showing
jay blexi over performing their rating
with four out of seven
whoever heartick is i don't know
congratulations four out of seven
and adi with a level score that's
impressive against this field with three
and a half
and where are the other regulars jobs
squared sounds familiar but i don't know
100
uh nick mike i think is a regular uh
what good showing by nick mike
steve north ending on two points but we
saw some pretty good games from from
steve
and uh i think orlando probably just
didn't show up for the games
unfortunate for orlando uh thank you all
so much for joining me here today there
he is
danny machuga the chess playing wolf
your road to 2000
champion if danny is interested in a
free private lesson
with me i'm sure he'll be in touch
and we will uh we will check it out
thank you all so much for
joining me here i had a blast doing this
tournament once again if this is the
type of thing you guys like
seeing uh maybe we'll do some more
tournament commentary on
the channel here uh but yeah that does
it for the roads 2000 tonight if you're
watching live
we are gonna have a pretty normal end
game lecture
nothing crazy like this back to normalcy
there
uh if you're watching the video version
thank you so much for checking out this
crazy crazy tournament hopefully you
guys enjoyed the action ton of crazy
stuff here tonight
i really enjoyed it as always my name is
caleb denby and i will see you
next time
you